- So, we were just
talking about giving back.
So you actually did,
was it a "Designing Women"
table read for charity?
Is that what I... that's amazing!
- We actually got together last year
and we read the pilot script.
- How fun was that?
- Yeah.
- From thirty five years ago,
something like that. (laughing)
- Yeah, that's crazy.
- And it was weird cause it
felt like we had just done it.
- [Kelly] Oh, really?
- And I could hear everybody's...
I could just hear everybody in my head
and how it used to be 'cause,
unfortunately, of course,
we didn't have um...
- [Kelly] Didn't have Dixie.
- [Jean] Dixie, and Delta
couldn't do it, so we, you know.
But it was just like we
had just been doing it.
It was crazy.
- Is there an episode
from "Designing Women"
that still kind of sticks out for you?
I have so many!
- Oh gosh, there was five years of them.
- Do you wanna know mine? Fine.
- Yeah, I'm dying to know
what your favorite is!
- Mine is when y'all were snowed in!
- Oh, "Reservations for Eight"
- And the guys and the girls,
were...
Yeah.
- Yeah, so we all got in a
- I loved that one.
big fights, the women against the men.
- I know, cause I love it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And of course the one
where I met my husband,
of course stands out.
That was the fifth episode of the season.
We hadn't even aired yet.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
- The show had never aired
and we were shooting episode number five
and he'd played Annie's boyfriend.
- Did you know right
away when you first met?
- We were never apart
after that day. (laughing)
- [Audience] Aww.
- Oh my gosh, really?
- Yeah.
I don't mean we moved in
together the next day.
I don't mean that!
(audience and Kelly laughing)
Don't mean that.
- This is happening.
- No, and he...
he invited me to come and
see a play that he was doing.
Of course I went 17 times.
(Kelly awing)
And then, you know, we lived
about 15 minutes apart,
but we would talk every night on the phone
for about two hours.
- I love that!
That's rare!